[Music]
hello I'm came early and welcome to a
special program in which I'm joined by a
hundred women from right across the UK
we agreed you weren't just going to sit
like that ladies didn't wait an hour of
live discussion and debate on how far
we've come in the last 100 years and how
much further we need to go for real
gender parity we're joined by a special
panel to discuss everything from sex
scandals equal pay and feminism to male
attitudes and whether other women
sometimes hold us back oh yeah you can
join in as well if you'd like via social
media we're using the hashtag 100 women
today do let us know your thoughts
before we do all that let's have a quick
look back at the journey so far in 100
seconds what about this ladies for
cutting bread in a hurry when there's
hungry youngsters come in for tea
everywhere suffragettes throw stones
shout train themselves to railings a
resist everything including a rest after
jail they go in there hundreds there to
endure a hunger strikes votes for women
marah's insistence on short skirts
amazed many buyers until they reflected
that girls in Milan and Minneapolis are
now demanding what Britain already has
[Music]
the lady's not for turning power woman
power just empowering women a
unprecedented incident in my 29 years
being a firefighter I have never ever
seen anything of this scale fed up with
not being treated the same not getting
the same lunch play just having to do
two jobs at the same time just it's
enough up
[Music]
neck's is gonna be a good program that
lets off with Danny cotton who was in
that video she's with us now hide any
young woman at the very top of your game
having been in the fire service for 30
years I think I'm right in saying have
you got to where you are I think
persistence having to believe in
yourself even when you've got huge
amounts of doubt and other people
criticizing you and not believing in you
and I think just by being determined and
by proving that you can be a woman and
do the top job and go through the ranks
and you're as good as a man doing it and
actually I think women bring different
skills to leadership and that's really
important and I think last year and the
tragedy of Grenville showed that it can
be really good to be a woman and lead
differently because I really care about
all the people who work for me in London
Fire Brigade what sort of challenges
have you faced straight off the bat
obviously we're going to more detail
later on yes I think the challenges are
that people still think the firefighting
isn't a job for women still challenging
the sort of gender term fireman and
still not having people fully behind us
and I think that some of the media
criticism there have been recently of me
trying to discuss gender-neutral
language and the animosity that's
brought has made me realise how you want
it to be firefighter Sam don't you
rather than fireman 17 you know to bring
it down to its lowest common denominator
what's wrong with that why shouldn't we
call in firefighter Sam do you think
it's just for me about inspiring young
girls in the next generation of
firefighters and giving all of our
children both boys and girls the
opportunity to do what job they want and
not be restricted by you know people who
have stereotypes yeah let me introduce
the rest of the panel not only to our
audience here but also to you at home
with us is actress Michelle Collins
everybody recognizes Michelle of course
at Labour MP for Ealing central and
Acton Rupa Hawk we've said allo to Danny
the consumer champion that's what we're
calling you today Kate Hardcastle does
that work what works for me and Sanders
first female commander Lieutenant
Colonel Lucy Giles who got a round of
applause last time I said that
[Applause]
it's less than well 1919 I think when we
first welcomed the first woman MP asked
her who we saw in that video Nancy Astor
how do you think things have changed for
women in Parliament in that time yeah I
mean I think the culture has changed but
the pace of change sometimes since
glacially slow so I mean when I take
people on a tour of the House of Commons
I was doing one this morning you come
through an arch that's been there since
1099 so I mean from 1099 to 1919 is a
long time and it took up till 1918 for
people to recognize when we are
intelligent enough to put an X in a box
every five years so I mean I mean I'm
very proud to say I'm part of the most
diverse Parliament ever one-in-three MPs
is now a woman I think it's the gayest
Parliament ever the most BME Parliament
ever but you know we can still go a lot
further on things like disability and
one in three is I'd say you've got at
the moment it's hopeless well I mean
yeah but I mean even in basically that
isn't it yes show them that as well all
the holes in the ceiling you know it's
literally you can see it caving in I
mean it's not enough to just pat
ourselves on the back and say job done
because one in three is not the same as
50/50 which it should be if it reflects
our population so I mean I think in 1997
where we had a hundred and one labour
women MP elected in the tide of Blair is
that Blair's babes yeah yeah that phrase
particularly did you yeah I mean I'm 45
years old I couldn't be a babe ever
we're not doing the point is they had to
convert a lot of toilets into women's
toilets it just wasn't there before the
infrastructure the whole setup of it is
like a gentlemen's club this sort of way
that we refer to each other I'm the
Honourable lady for Ealing central in
acting it's really bad to refer to
someone by their name you get really
slapped down and frowned upon so this
Victorian play-acting that we have in
the House of Commons some of those
structures you know they I mean
tradition is good but I mean some of
them for the sake of it and then also
recently we've had debates on things
like on baby leave because MPs who have
kids while they're in there I mean I did
all that before I really liked
there there are these sort of things
like they vote for you they work for you
that they sort of count they audit every
time an MP votes so colleagues of mine
who've had kids they've been rated by
the Sun as the laziest MP in England or
whatever and it's because you have to go
through a physical lobby
you know the struck the structures and
structures that you have to do there
should be some ways around that because
it's not that they're slumming it you
know can I bring in Lucy Charles you're
in one of the most male-dominated fields
in the whole world
I mean how have you risen to the top
well I don't come from a military
background I I joined the army straight
from school through via University and I
was encouraged by my friends to to join
the army and and do the thing called the
Officer Training Corps but the thing
that attracted me with the army was
because I enjoyed working with the
people and I tried to did to have a
foray into looking at joining the media
but the people Wednesday no seriously
the it was the challenge it was it was
it was travel it was doing different
things and and so many different
experiences so I joined with that
culture I didn't really notice in a way
that I was in a very stark minority
there are a few things that you when you
say minority I mean there's just over 12
percent women in the British are well
we're looking at in you know increasing
that 15 percent by 2020 that saw our
target it's not a lot is there what is
it that we could improve 7 percent women
7 in London Fire Brigade less than that
in the UK fire service about 3 percent
in the UK and what are you doing about
it we're doing lots of positive recruit
we're starting a new recruitment
campaign tomorrow for International
Women's Day and we're specifically
trying to target women and talk about
the role of a firefighter and how
different it is now and you know how
many different skills you need and that
women make great firefighters as far as
your industry is concerned I mean
there's a lot of women isn't there but
it as actresses but they treated
differently to men
um yes and now obviously you know I
can't it's very difficult because I
can't play a guy so we're obviously not
up for the same roles I think equal pay
definitely comes into it obviously as we
all know in the past and recent you know
I did I'm ever doing him a job it was a
promotional job with an actor quite a
well-known actor I won't say who he was
and and he was always talking about
money as men tend to do they tend to
talk about money a lot and we sort of
don't I don't if it's because we've
British or because of it all we don't
need to talk about money I'm not gonna
and I just listened to him he was
bragging about how much he was getting
and I said I went what and just quietly
went back and got onto the phones my
agent said do you know he's getting this
and she said what so then she went we
were in the same agency but with
different agents and got my money out so
you know I do think I mean of course
it's different because actresses you
know we go off and it's generally us
that when we have children we take
maternity leave the men don't normally
take the maternity leave so and then
it's harder to go it's when you go back
to work it's like you know our on a
women's group and it's very difficult
for women who have and statistically I
think when women have children they go
back to work and generally they don't go
back to the position that they were in
when they left in surgery it's tougher
it's true and it's also also you know
god help you if you're an actress and
you get to 45 because your career will
really change it would totally change
them as well quick thought
from UK before we bring in our audience
so do you find I mean when we think
about entrepreneurs we don't necessarily
think that men do better than women do
they well I think there's a really
interesting idea around the word
entrepreneurs to start with because
sometimes it can be masking a challenge
that we've got in the business economy
and that is a lot of ladies who as
Michelle just mentioned you have child
you get to a certain point in life maybe
you're caring for an elderly parent and
you have to almost invent a business for
yourself to find the hours and find the
working environment that suits you and
as part of my business I do a giveback
of 20% of my time and I meant to those
businesses and I speak to predominately
the women that run them and and they
don't always choose to be like that they
do you know everything they can to earn
the money they can in the hours that
they've got available and I think this
which we can do but I mean you can see
in the boardrooms around the world so
much more needs to be done and I will
tell you for sure a balanced business
room by a balance of people will be a
better more comfortable business okay
let's bring in our Raja sir thank you
for that kelly Maloney is here with us
hi Kelly delighted that you with us
today thank you you're a former boxing
manager of course aren't you and a
campaigner on transgender and diversity
issues of late what's your life
experience taught you about equality I
think you definitely get treated
different as a female as a person who's
lived in two genders as a man I had
really different roles and different
expectations of me and you know I walked
out of boxing and I came back into
boxing as a female but the level
differences did you see well I'm just
saying okay back my licenses because the
level respects our head yeah as a female
was totally different to what Frank
Moloney had I actually had to remind a
couple of officials that I hadn't had a
brain transplant I just modified my body
so it's very hard and you did feel so
strongly that you did you did you it was
it a conscious decision to give up that
or did you feel that you had no choice
and they would have been taken away from
you anyway well I think it's very hard
you know you if you're a in the boxing
world unless you're with the elite
promotional set up or with a TV company
is a very hard business to be in and I
felt because of what I've achieved as
frame I wasn't going to put myself
through that stress that bother I'd
rather live a much more peaceful life
and do other things do you think it's
good you're female or do you think it's
because you're transgender um a little
bit of both because some some sections
of female community do not accept
house-trained women as women I mean I
listen to the lady MP there's talking
about diversity but there are no trans
people in the houses of commons so right
yeah I mean as I say on some of these
things we're really slow and it's very
hard for a trans person to get on so
even to an all-women's party group these
days there's a lot of she she left today
did she yeah she left yesterday
yeah yesterday
here on sky so how much further do we
need to go obviously we're here what's
happening in the house of gods but you
are being I mean you come on programs
like this we've seen you on Big Brother
and life haven't we and you're blazing
the trail yet transgender women we are
we are getting it very slowly but where
it's taken women 200 years since they
got the boat you know we are we're a
long way of being accepted fully in in
females community properly I believe you
know there are a group out there
I think it's called woman's place who
are so empty trains they do everything
to stop us and they they criticizes and
I personally am at the moment having
major rather than on my Twitter account
so I've just decided to block the best
way forward now I'm just gonna do a
quick show of hands ladies we weren't
going to do this at the end but I want
to do it now and then I want you to
think about it and then we're gonna do
it again at the end and the question is
this we've come a long way in a hundred
years since some women or women some
women first got the vote women who were
thirsty I think I'm writing over 13
years also were married yeah so how much
longer how much further do you think we
need to go how much longer do you think
it will take for gender parity globally
so that's a question that we're going to
ask you anybody think it's ten years
anybody think it's 20 years it'll it's
equal what about 50 years hundred years
100 years okay that's what our audience
is so be really really interested to
hear what you think about that at home
how long do you think it's going to take
until we have gender parity globally
according to the World Economic Forum do
get involved at home tweeters using the
hash tag 100 women
[Music]
let's move on to what is perhaps one of
the biggest issues for women the fight
for equal pay those are grown in the
audience in our exclusive sky data poll
70% of both men and women surveyed told
us that they believe men are paid more
for doing the same job 70% think that
men are being paid more for doing the
same job what does our audience think
what do you think do you think that men
are generally paid more for doing the
same job anybody want to offer a view on
that lady at the back there yes madam I
don't think necessarily I mean
particularly in the industry that I work
you know work currently work in social
services and I previously trained as a
primary school teacher so works in
education as well both very much
female dominated environments and I
think particularly jobs for jobs on the
same pay scale you are paid the same but
I think particularly things that are
viewed as women's work teaching social
care cleaner admin secretarial
receptionists are generally paid less
than jobs that would perhaps be quite
similar that a generally dominated by
men like the difference between what a
cleaners paid and the difference between
those who collect little spins kind of a
similar field work but the pay
difference between the two is is quite
staggering anybody else in the audience
this lady here in in the middle please
with the black jacket on absolutely
madam I work in the IT industry and I
couldn't positively say that male and
female we get paid more or less the same
which is encouraging and I think that
many more young women should come
forward to work with in the IT industry
okay so growth industry come along girls
[Applause]
more than you was it sort of it was
sorta - it was sorted out do you think
it's still the issue yes III do I mean
you know I suppose I've been fortunate
enough that over the years I've had
leading roles in dramas and and as I
said we don't
don't really talk about what I'm getting
paid I don't it's something I don't I
like to keep quite private but maybe now
is the time not to keep it private and
as I said before learn about the women
from the BBC to come out in force and
said look this is what I'm owning I
think it's brilliant we need to this is
where now times are changing and we need
to start talking about it and and also
its solidarity isn't it I think women if
it's just one woman you're really scared
to go and complain about well I just
found out that getting paid more to more
than me and I think women a frightened
that they might get the sack or but
what's happening now is because we're
all together it's solidarity we'd go in
as a group then we can we are much
stronger and it's a bit you know there
was a the open letter that 70 female
writers wrote to the BBC about how they
felt that female writers were
underrepresented on TV and there was 70
of them and it was brilliant because it
was it's so much more powerful when
you've got a group of women as opposed
to one and I think it's fantastic that
times are really changing we're not
gonna be embarrassed anymore to talk
about what we're owning I'm certainly
not going to be because obviously we
need to be the world is becoming so much
more transparent absolutely how Catholic
I mean it was the 1970s Barbara castle
the Dagon and women it is illegal to pay
women less than men it is still
happening and they I season had it said
to me when I found out that a colleague
in a similar role was being paid
significantly more well you should have
asked so that the sort of commentary I
used to get being one of the only female
board members in organisations but I
think it's about us building bridges and
not thrones I think it's about not
looking after ourselves quite as much as
looking after us and the future
generations and being the true battle
carriers that were ahead of us and that
is going to involve some uncomfortable
conversations I'm more than happy to
mentor support any person within the
workplaces I've been in and be
completely transparent about the pay
that I've had the benefits have received
and help them negotiate a better deal
but we shouldn't be putting the onus
back when we know that naturally we're
very different anyway and we know that
test we know the test that the man looks
at the interview sheet and says if
there's five or more things I can sort
of describe all the things I can do I'll
apply and we looking or can we do 10 out
the 10 before we apply so
it's not in our nature always to do that
and therefore the employers themselves
need to be far more responsible
left-handed colonel men and women to pay
the same any army yes if we're all there
to do a particular job to serve our
country and doesn't matter if you're a
male or female doing that job you get
paid the same 75 service yep brilliant
it's great because it means there's a
man or woman joining the fire service
you are going to get the same pay and
you don't have to fight for it is your
rights and you don't have to ask for it
because that is what you're going to get
paid and and the whole thing I think
that women are sometimes shy and coming
forward and I think sometimes when women
get to a certain job or rank if they've
never got there before then they kind of
in some ways feel grateful they're there
and then don't provide the challenge or
because they're isolated and and
sometimes a woman's far less likely on a
board to say to the other guys well what
are you actually earning because they
don't want highlight themselves because
they are one you know group of many men
so I think it is time the honesty bit is
great I think if we are supporting each
other and being honest and right across
the peace from public to private sector
I think now is the time for us all to
stand together because by doing that we
are building the bridges for the next
generation and we're there we should be
role modeling that behavior it's so
important because people look to us and
if we're not doing it how will a young
girl coming through or you new young
apprentice ever have the courage to do
it and please pay the same yeah I mean
our basic salary is the same and it's
very transparent and open what we're
paid but I think there was a report
recently that showed that with all the
outside earnings men earn more so they
often will have a second job lowering or
something like that whereas I think with
all these arguments we've got to look
also at the workplace why is it always
the woman's fault for not asking if
you're in a job where it's macho men in
suits and if you stay all the hours God
sends then you're a good employee that
is not conducive to going home to do bed
time you know the sort of thing I do
I'll be doing tonight whereas a man
wouldn't you know men are carers to
their parents too but the onus is often
on the woman isn't it so I mean I think
we need to look at our workplaces
because these structures and
cultures are designed by men for men
aren't they yeah there is a House of
Commons nursery but then there's issues
about between nursery age and schooling
to do a gag about it being the chamber
then stop you lady here yes please stop
a second and then we'll get the
microphone toward you there yeah thank
you
I think it's picking up on something
Rupert said as well those bids are the
factors at play and and often it's the
woman that takes on the caring role I
was in 2004 I was at the top of my game
in a marketing career and then bang my
my child was born very very disabled and
I had to give up my job and cared for
her for 12 years until until she died
last year and and now I'm trying to
re-enter the workplace and the
colleagues who were at the same level as
me 12 years ago have gone on you know
they're in the stratosphere and I'm now
at a completely different level so sorry
what can you do about that
well I mean in terms of carers
acknowledging that it is often the woman
who becomes the Karen it's not just
caring for a child caring for a disabled
child and where I couldn't I physically
couldn't go back to work caring for an
elderly relative I mean we're very much
I'm very much sort of the Sandwich
Generation we have children in school
and we have elderly relatives people our
parents are living longer and how are we
supporting the invisible women who have
had to step out of a career and be at
home and provide for free a caring role
okay anybody else want to jump in the
lady there with glasses beautiful red
hair just hold on one second while we
get the microphone to you there we are
one thing that sort of hasn't really
been touched upon is the idea of you
know equal pay in the workplace it's
brilliant and but how does that transfer
to smaller businesses as well we've all
talked about you know acting the
military things like that and having
sort of a consensus on equal pay but as
someone that works for a very small
business you know is there anything that
can be done to ensure that that carries
across to those small businesses as well
okay you want to come back
think small businesses often in my
experience can be a lot fairer the more
personable and therefore they can feel
the responsibility to you because
they've got that relationship if I was
gonna start beating up some of the
people in business believe me it would
start and some of the bigger ones you
know having some of those major UK
brands have their boardrooms not equal
in balance it in any way in any
diversity and yet be prepared to sell to
that person every day makes my blood
boil so you know I don't actually think
in the main small businesses tend to be
the unfairest okay if you want to get
involved at home of course do tweeters
I've got my phone here in front of me I
can read everything that you have to say
keep it clean please use the hashtag 100
women Graham whetstone has tweeted a
very good afternoon to you Graham the
biggest and best influence on my life
was my mum I miss her guidance and
advice every day but I can still hear
her voice in my head what's the biggest
influence on you ladies very quickly my
grandmother brought up my mother during
the Second World War having lost her
husband he was a Canadian Royal Air
Force pilot when she was six months
pregnant and she's been absolute
inspiration she's 95 still alive still
fighting fit and amazing woman
yeah I've got a mixture of them I think
what got me into labor
it was probably Neil killing when he's
always lose a selection see feminists he
was definitely my mum I was brought up
by a single parent my my sister live my
mom she's constant inspiration she went
back to get a degree when I was 13 and
she's just amazing and she taught us how
important education was to read how
important books were and to go out and
and and do what you really wanted to do
Germany sir Roderick who was kind enough
to give me great advice and told me
don't think you small if you think you
smile spend the night with a Miss Kate's
mosquito in your bed and you'll know
about obviously my parents but I've
always had been influenced by a pretty
impressive OC when I was in my first
tour in Bosnia david shuster myth okay
so it's really important to be very
influential on your children's lives is
what we are gathering
from our audience let's bring in Natasha
Jonas should we you are a mum of course
you're also an Olympian and you are a
boxer did one of those have to give or
bend until it almost broke when the
children were growing up him at the now
that she's in their own routine the
professional boxing side she's in you
know doctor she comes with it and she's
an arrow and routine she goes to nursery
I've got massive support from my family
which helps with the babysitting and you
know the times they have to spend the
way and compete and you feel guilt as a
mother and I wonder do men feel the same
sort of guilt I don't know I'm just
putting it out there I mean I was a
single mom and I often went out on
assignment and so I had to make sure
that well I actually just left him under
the stairs with a smile Marie was fine
it was fine it was like anybody else I
mean who feels that it is a this lady
here do you find it it's more or less of
a challenge being a mother as to being a
father yes just wait for the microphone
there we go yes I do feel guilt
sometimes I have an international job
I've worked in international roles for
10 years so I travel a lot and it's when
the children say mommy when are you
coming back next time please don't go
away
I got stranded in the snow last week 27
hours to get back from Northern Ireland
Wow
so yeah it can be difficult but at the
same time you have other
responsibilities so it's balancing those
responsibilities okay let's bring out
Alex to pledge Alex you're a successful
tech entrepreneur tell us what happened
though to you because quite often we
were hearing about which sort of
businesses might be more supportive when
it comes to being pregnant not all
businesses are very supportive when it
comes to being pregnant what was your
experience so I think so I had my first
child in 2015 shortly after raising
about 4 million pounds for my technology
startup and it wasn't particularly
welcomed by the investment community is
probably the nicest way to say it and I
you find that quite difficult because I
think as in sports and as in acting and
a lot there's only two point I've just
over 2% of investment goes into
female-led businesses at least in 2016
and I think the relationship between
investors and founders is broken in the
sense
that there is no traditional hierarchy
of like a hitch a function or the kind
of employee/employer relationship and so
when that breaks down you have nowhere
to go
and I think that you can see that
happening with actors and in sports and
it definitely happens in tech and
because we haven't had that me to momen
if you look at technology no one's
really come out with these stories and
yet I hear them on a daily basis I was
on my way in here today and I got a call
from one of the girls I meant when she'd
been in investment meeting with some
very seniors investors that if I'm in
their names you would know them and she
was mocked while she was trained to
trying to raise investment for a company
and I think this happens all the time
but we have nowhere to express it and to
do so it's - whistle blow and whistle
blow it is to risk your credibility and
so you keep silent and I think until we
get some mechanisms that go beyond the
individual for example like at the FDA
regulating venture capitalists with
ethics and discriminatory ministry and
measured snot when they're raising that
fund or getting that fund approved again
they are looking at some of these um
these factors we have nowhere to go for
that outlet and I think that needs to to
come to the front okay not everybody
thinks that the older generation are a
good influence on as caroline has
tweeted me this afternoon hello to you
Caroline must we always have to pay for
older generations mistakes some of us
don't want to burn our bras we just want
to be paid the same as men for the same
job let us know your thoughts so you can
tweet me directly if you would like to
act capability
[Music]
let's move on to one of the hot topics
in this centenary year sex scandals and
sexism oh yeah
Harvey Weinstein the male only dinner at
a swanky London hotel where hostesses
were encouraged to dress provocatively
and of course the me to campaign all
this prompts the question have men
really changed their attitudes towards
women you're going to absolutely be
surprised at this result let's ask the
audience most of all before I tell you
doing result of this poll do you think
men have changed their attitude towards
women as a result of sexism sexual abuse
and the the way it's been highlighted in
the media over the last three to six
months yes do you think men have changed
their attitudes and now do you don't
think men of change you actually put
your hands up if you think that men have
not changed your attitude so I'm gonna
say that's about 60% so 40% if you think
that they possibly have for who thinks
that men have changed their attitudes
some men some men you wanna see the
results of our poll have a look over
here ladies here we go three-quarters of
men say they have not changed their
behavior or attitudes towards women as a
result of what we've seen panel who
would like to start oh you're shaking
your head in the middle I genuinely
don't think a lot of men think they have
to because what's the sanction for
majority of men unless you are in the
position where you're you know in a high
profile job and getting caught for a lot
of men nothing actually happens they
don't lose out in the job world they
don't lose out anywhere you know and I
think that there is nothing that's set
in stone I mean there are some great
people there's some great men out there
who behave brilliantly and are role
models but for a lot of men there is no
encouragement there's no support and
they're seen as weak sometimes if they
do change their behavior change
overnight there is it that's I think
it's it's it's educating young men a
very young age I think to respect women
and to treat women as equals and getting
them when they're very young
Amanda how do you make jokes about oh
I'm not supposed to touch you now or
what better be careful I'm not and think
it's really funny yeah no names no back
Patra but I went to a quite a swish
restaurant
with one of my colleagues recently and a
very very senior conservative politician
said come over here and let me sexually
harass you oh I'm not supposed to say
that anymore
bash around the face a little bit
I mean how ridiculous is that you still
probably in the world of politics people
will think twice because if you think
about it the expense of scandal sort of
as a result of that we've now got
procedures in place for claiming
expenses whereas before that you know
when Michael Fallon said that times are
different now to ten to fifteen years
ago I think what you meant is you could
get away with more ten to fifteen years
ago men will do what they can get away
with
whereas now we've got a system for
financial impropriety you're not I mean
I was elected in 2015 I'm never going to
claim for a duck house because I'm very
aware it's all going to be published but
I can tell them there was no
transparency in all that that's what it
took to have a proper system I think it
was a good thing it was you know
unpleasant to hear about it but it was a
necessary thing I think in quite balance
and I think there's a few things to be
said here I mean I've got my dad who set
a probably league team just so his
daughter could play because there wasn't
one that the female PE teachers would
let me play in and then mail manage and
Ericsson CEOs it recognized my talent
got me sitting at business school did
all that brilliant thing and then also
been in a factory floor at a very young
girl begging people to take topless
posters down I've really truly gone on
each side of this but working with young
men in schools and colleges one thing I
do understand about behavior and having
soon as well as daughters is that
sometimes that behavior is almost like a
pact thing and they and they have so
many confidence issues to not do the way
that they enforce to behave almost
sometimes and it's an education process
as well as they're just well let's just
shove many more I mean I said I see this
to these statistics and my heart drops
yep because we are trying so hard I
couldn't be change the culture I said
are we sure we did we asked that
question and this is what they say at
unbelievable we have a network called us
and her sisterhood and in that network
when this
this all sort of happened a few months
ago it did raise a few skeletons from
the closet of people in the particularly
in the 80s and in the 90s who to
experience have had some bad experiences
and I remember what following the
traffic and what was interesting it
wasn't necessarily just my reaction when
our senior leadership got to hear about
it and they did they were devastated
they were genuinely devastated because
there is no excuse at all for any
inappropriate about it well we've got
policies in place but more importantly
because that's just paperwork isn't it
yeah what we got to do is we've got to
change the culture from the bottom up
yeah and and certainly if you look at
what we're doing at Sandhurst in the
last three years we've integrated all
our training got men and women trained
together training as we fight so that we
can stop what inadvertently we're doing
which was creating a bit of massagin ism
by having women trained separately and
the top down can I just say who is a
political commentator and previously
speech writer for top politicians as
tweeted high essure say does the me to
campaign the hashtag mean nothing when
75 percent of men have not changed their
attitude towards women despite the
Weinstein and President's Club scandals
keep you thoughts coming in on that if
you would audience this lady here in
with the glasses and the green shop just
here just here come this way go there we
go thanks guys just wait for them at
there we are I'm really disappointed to
see those statistics because I think men
have such an important role to play in
helping this movement a hundred years
ago when women first got the right to
vote there was a league called the men's
league for women's suffrage and those
men used their positions of power to
help women get the right to vote and I
would love to see a similar movement now
a movement by men that could help women
get into positions of power in politics
and in business right now we have 32
percent of MPs that a female in
leadership roles in business it's 22%
women so most of the decision-makers are
men if we could use their energy that
power to help this cause it would make
such a difference
Eddie over there in the red just wait
for the microphone thank you madam I
think we had work in this field and in
the corporate world and I think what's
happened in in the years since I started
working this in the 80s where we thought
it should be 50% in everything
and so I don't know where that didn't
happen I think what's happened is a lot
of intellectual recognition
everybody's got diversity committees for
everything but actually when you scratch
the surface at a beliefs level we
haven't tapped into that we really
haven't got many of the most senior
people understanding at a gut level
until sometimes they experience it
sometimes when it's their daughter who
is passed over because I was just
talking to a chief executive before I
came in and he was saying I'm appalled
that people have been saying to our
women you're off to International
Women's Day is that to get your nails
done and he was a classic knitting club
they get but he was a classic person who
you know had a daughter it was just
going into to work I mean is so weird
you know what though I think it's fair
to say ladies I don't know how you feel
that you know it's not just you know
we're looking at men in in in that poll
but it's not just men sometimes I find
that women are not as supportive as they
might be to other women and there's a
great quotes that I try menti quite a
few young girls and I always say to them
there's a special it's Madeline Albright
actually he was the former US Secretary
of State and I always say there's a
special place in hell for women who
don't support other women and I think we
need to to remember
[Applause]
you are a model and a campaigner and
you've had this experience as well yeah
I think debates we all have and I think
it's so important that we take
responsibility as females for the fact
that you know we are this movement is
about us but we also control it it's
really important you know it's a really
dangerous culture and it's too normal
it's too normal it's you know we go on
social media and you the comments you
read from women's other women and it's
about we look like it's even about how
people parent they'll be ripped apart
for how they bring up their children you
know we buy into it as well you know
magazines are telling us that you know
we I'm apparently not a real woman
because I'm curvy you know I know you
often see curvy women get it as well and
you know you're I'm told that I can't
age as a woman you absolutely can't but
damned if you try to fix it with
cosmetic surgery because then you're
fake it's a constant domino effect and
it's it's so sad because we're so savage
to the people no the argument base we're
all women we're all going through it so
without sticking together I mean imagine
if we all did stick together I didn't
put that height out there we would
literally be the living embodiment of
the Spice Girls facing women have been
supportive to you yes I know I've been
very lucky but going back to the sex
scandal for yeah I mean I think it's men
of a certain age because obviously I was
at the top of my career in the 90s we
made sure it was across you know most of
my business had to be done in strip
joints or let dancing clubs and in some
cases to get some contracts signed and I
won't mention which promoters they are I
actually had to provide women with women
hookers for them to sign the contracts
let's get certain deals done so I think
it how do you feel about that now I've
done that I try not to think about it
now if I'm honest but it was the world I
lived in
and I'm thought you know it's a world
where like it's sport I mean in women's
football teams I'm really well in the
World Cup
yet one of the FAA officials come and
said well we'll forget about and they're
they've got to return home they're just
mums and wife's but I mean don't mean
footballers turn home aren't they
husbands and fathers you know say some
it is a finger but I think it's sort of
men in certain little clubs yeah okay
well I will come back to you in a second
ladies if you wouldn't mind as I said do
let us know what you think we very much
appreciate your opinion apparently we
are trending on Twitter at the moment
ladies that's nice isn't it let us know
what you think
[Music]
okay let's move on to our final parties
we're seeing through aren't we with our
discussion about feminism and royalty oh
yeah last week Meghan Michael announced
Prince Harry is a feminist and said
women don't need to find a voice they
have a voice they need to feel empowered
to use it and people need to be
encouraged to listen so who here
considers themselves a feminist anybody
who doesn't consider themselves a
feminist lady at the back with the pink
top yeah why are you not a feminist and
I don't necessarily would class myself
as a feminist because I genuinely
believe that we are equal so I don't
believe that a woman should have better
rights than a man a man should have
better rights than a woman because we
are all the same and I personally
haven't experienced any gender anything
against me for being a woman
it always has been in my life so I think
I've been pretty lucky okay okay we're
gonna come back and get some more
thoughts from you in just a second
ladies I have to say that I have a very
close male friend who describes himself
as a feminist so men can be feminists as
well as women but what did our sky data
poll say here we go there we go are you
a feminist only two thirds of people
asked said that they were a feminist
whereas around 1/3 said that they were
are you a family 34% two thirds saying
no they weren't so that you're not
really reflective are you here ladies
today what do we make of this poll and
what do we think yeah hold on oh you've
got your mic on yeah wait yeah I think
you don't have to necessarily identify
as a feminist to care about women's
rights so actually if you embrace the
term you said we shouldn't be using
labels I think I think we shouldn't give
up the struggle for women's rights
because there are issues around the word
feminist or feminism lady fair with the
lovely bow in her hair or is it
sunglasses it's sunglasses I am I
worried about what feminists what
feminism means
to people what does it mean to you well
it means equal rights for men and women
it means equality in its absolute so for
me
who the hell wouldn't be a feminist it
literally makes no lady here on the end
with the floral top yeah yep hi yeah I
think that the term feminism is is still
using a negative context and it really
shouldn't be to me being a feminist or
into feminism is just being empowered to
be you're a woman be can be whoever you
want to be enjoy it embrace it it's you
know it's nothing to you know people
automatically think oh okay she's it
must be into burning bras and doing
marches it's it's not at all it's
basically you know giving everyone you
know empowerment so to just do your own
thing it's 2018 you know just in equal
equal equality for everyone really lady
here with a black top on gold bracelet
just know just that yep yes you as a
small business owner I'm and coming from
down in in Devon as well which is a
little bit further from here I'm I'm
also in an industry where it's very
male-dominated and with children having
mummy guilt and and seeing all you
lovely ladies up there and what you're
doing and also how we need to embrace
and empower other women I have been
through some things personally but I'm
very cautious of the fact that you know
we need to stand together and there
shouldn't be a male or female it should
be very equal it is hard to be a
feminist because as an owner of business
you don't want to be seen as you know
it's hard to be a man in in our world
and I've got three five sons three my
own sorry two of my partners and I want
them to all feel that you know they
should look up and aspire to be the best
person they can be although Chenery one
of our sports reporters has tweeted to
say great news on women's cycling the
ovo energy women's tour
to offer equal prize money to men's to a
Briton raise price funding going from
35,000 euros to 90 thousand euros we
very build an air of an hour today when
people ask me am i a feminist you know
in the 70s and 80s when I was growing up
you would either be a feminist where you
would burn your bra or you would be
feminine where you would you know talk
about lipstick and curls in your hair
I'd like to describe myself as a
feminine feminist that's how I see
myself it's almost become a little bit
jaded the word and it has too many
connotation we need to rebrand Michel as
they say and I think you know my
daughter said what you know she's a 21
year old clever Brister University and
she said well I don't want to be defined
why should I have to define myself I yes
I'm leaving equal I'm in equality so
does my partner but so you know now I
think hashtag me - hashtag times
time's up time for change that's what
people are saying more maybe that's the
way you should be going and I do think
it's you know someone talked about
women's lib earlier and burning your
brow and I just can't believe it was
it's quite comical in a way isn't it and
I think you know I I'm a feminist I
totally a feminist but sometimes I do
you know you shouldn't we shouldn't
condemn somebody Bjork decided she
wasn't gonna be a feminist she's not a
feminist and a lot of people condemned
her and she's the most individual artist
but we have an a very independent female
woman and it's up to her that she
doesn't want to be a feminist I think we
in this sorry I was just gonna say I
think in this day and age particular
with social media it is very word
oriented and yet if you go back to the
original movement it was deeds not words
and I think we shall know he was ladies
I'm sure you know suffragettes me I
can't do anything but be grateful to all
of those before hers I mean I revisited
everything last night and I was looking
even advertisements for jobs used to be
in mail columns and female columns you
know so much progress so utterly
grateful for that but maybe now it is
because there are so many fragments of
feminism time to just start looking at
the deeds yeah the first thing I asked
David Cameron in the house to come
in 2015 when I was first elected was
would he call himself because you're not
allowed to refer to people by name you
know I say you that's really bad in the
House of Commons so what do you call
himself a feminist and he said well if
it means equality for women yes of
course I am because 30% of my cabinet
and women like I'm no statistician but
70/30 I mean the point is it is laudable
aims to be associated with I think
people that have given it a bad press
associating it with dungarees and
bra-burning and sparerib and all that
you've got to look at who those people
are propagating those arguments and it's
usually sort of people who don't want
women to with them if I may do you have
male feminists in the army absolutely if
you my husband's serving and if if we're
defining feminism as wanting an
education in a profession that's equal
then of course he's a feminist I think
it's it's it's quite simple really
but but interesting for the various
places that I've gone to you see places
where it is massively unequal and huge
problems in different parts of the world
where we we serve and we try and make a
difference yeah I think the photogate I
think are there are fantastic men in my
organization who are very supportive of
wanting to make the fire brigade look
more like the community we were a
minority I don't think so no and I think
that now when people talk about things
that are sexist there's far more people
who are ready to stand up and say that's
not right but I just think as women as
well we sometimes need to stop
apologizing for wanting that to happen
absolutely I think we are quite guilty
of feeling you know is that we have to
you know it's really awkward but can I
and I think that we just need to be
proud of where we've got to but actually
continuing the fight together and
involving men because men are the
biggest advocates when they are
supportive and then it doesn't become a
battle and I think that I'm definitely
the uniformed services at the military I
think that you know people are
professional they're there to do a job
they're there to serve a community and
that's really important and people
understand that if you're there and
doing that together as a team
there is no
space for people to be different we have
to be together and work and I think as
well it's it's about empowering people
to step in and call it out if something
is going wrong have that voice and be
able to you know call it out it says is
inappropriate behavior or if anything's
going wrong and I have the strength to
know that you have behind you it isn't
deport you of course you can get
involved at home if you would like to
use that hashtag 100 women
lalana Heil Alana has tweeted me to say
I wish we had this one hundred women
trending 365 days a year all of us need
to keep empowering ourselves daily and
be supportive worldwide be inspired not
only by famous women but also women in
your communities and families that's
fabulous sir also very very keen to hear
what you think I'm not heard from a lot
of men today
don't be frightened we don't fight we
just want to know what you think as well
and thank you to all of you who are
feminists um this morning I was chatting
to our register at large and presenter
Adam Bolton who I've known for 30 odd
years and the end of a chat I had with
him he said if you could change one
thing to make women's lives better what
would it be I thought that was a great
question I thought maybe you ladies
might have a view on that the lady with
the beautiful bangle on just here there
we are
me yeah I think it's it's important
going forward to actually give when give
women all women a voice because I think
sometimes this gets lost in a
conversation like the conversation we're
having to this is quite homogeneous when
we talk about women I think that's
something that perhaps we could talk
about a bit more we're not all women's
voices I sometimes being heard
particularly women from minority groups
or people coming out of developing
countries
okay well moody's what's the end of the
program ladies so let's get these
dancers in quick fire or questions or
whatever you want to do lady here with a
pink scarf I think for me it's about but
that when you've reached a senior
position in a corporate world or the
business that you're in
you then have an excuse potentially that
you're too busy now you've made it to
the big time and I think one of the
message
and legacies we can leave for our
children our daughters is to have more
of those senior women mentoring starting
from the school and working at a much
younger age so that we give our
daughters the confidence to have those
voices and also the sons to respect
those daughters in those classrooms one
more one more lady here
I think it's quite interesting how what
are the things that would change
everything is helping I was thinking of
maybe going back to the
consciousness-raising groups of that we
had in the seventies but maybe what we
need now our men's consciousness-raising
groups where when men are saying oh I
have daughters I want things to change
why were they not indignant for their
wives why were they not indignant when
their mothers tell them stories
my mother-in-law told a story about no
being addressed in a big group of people
with qualifications and they went round
dr. professor and Julie but it's so
infuriating isn't it I think my dad was
probably a feminist as well he's brought
up two very strong-minded girls
certainly thank you very much indeed for
your thoughts we're going to come back
to you in just a second ladies but
remember at the top of the program we
asked how far away we were from gender
parity worldwide remember that put your
hands up ladies if you think we can
achieve gender parity in the next 50
years you can join in in the next 50
years okay yes okay do you think we
might reach gender parity worldwide in
the next 100 years does anyone think it
will be more than a hundred and fifty
years before we reach gender parity what
do you think well according to the
latest figures from the World Economic
Forum gender equality is still more than
200 years away 200 years away still an
awful way to go then quick thought
I'm not gonna be around you knew didn't
you well now I might win the bet for
being closest to the target but I'm you
know I think that's the sad state of
affairs something oK we've done a lot in
six months haven't we George the debate
by social media using the hashtag 100
women if you would like to remember on
Sky News we have a day of coverage to
mark International Women's Day which is
tomorrow of course and before that
coming up at half past 5:00 we'll be
reflecting on some of the issues raised
in this special program some of our
panelists will be staying with us for
that and our most senior woman at
Westminster Beth Ruby will be with us as
well so if you've got any thoughts use
that hashtag 100 women and don't forget
you can watch this program again at 8
o'clock tonight for now though thanks to
our panel Michelle Collins Roopa hawk
Danny cotton Kate Hardcastle and left
Hannah Cole Lucy Charles and of course
to our studio audience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]